[Music]
this episode and others like it are made
possible by the generous support of my
patrons on patreon
YouTube has demonetized almost all of my
recent videos so if you're able please
consider supporting this channel by
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
second thought so we are now just under
a thousand deaths a day from this virus
roughly 70,000 infections per day
ICUs are nearly full and the state is
preparing for the outbreak to get much
worse as just yesterday on Sunday
an additional 86 people died here in
Arizona so we do have to try to get kids
back into school we need to be mindful
that we may see a wave of these post
viral syndromes happening right when
we're trying to do that another looming
situation facing Arizona the opening of
schools set for next month there is no
nothing in the data that would suggest
that kids being back in school is is
dangerous to that one law firm is
offering free wills for Wisconsin
teachers these Oklahoma teachers
scrambling to draft their wills I'm
pretty sure I'm not gonna make it
I mean you know compromise so what we
want to do is we want to get our schools
open we want to get them open quickly
beautifully in the fall it's very
important for our country it's very
important for the well-being of the
student and the parents so we're gonna
be putting a lot of pressure on open
your schools in default the end of
summer and the beginning of a new school
year is something that most parents
eagerly look forward to and that their
children dread this year things are a
little different
while many working-age parents are
hoping to be able to send their kids
back to school so they can go to work
those kids do actually have something to
be afraid of this time with the US
facing a surge of new coronavirus cases
amid our complete failure to contain the
disease funneling millions of children
into high-density schools seems like a
good way to make things even worse in
this episode we're going to talk about
the push to reopen schools for the fall
semester and why that's a terrible idea
before we begin let's go over the
current situation since the kovat
situation is evolving so rapidly this
information is obviously subject to
change so be aware that the following
data was collected on July 20th 2020 and
reflects the most up-to-date information
at the time of writing this script we
are currently experiencing the worst
period yet of new cases and death
thanks to our uniquely terrible response
to the pandemic the United States stands
alone as the worst case scenario for the
spread of the disease at least 33
countries have banned travelers from the
US in an attempt to protect their
citizens from the rampant incompetence
of the world's greatest superpower the
epicenter of kovat infections has
shifted from cities like New York to
places like Texas and Florida each of
which is struggling to keep up with the
surge of cases often running out of
hospital beds in populous counties as
Texas Post record numbers of new cases
often over 10,000 per day the country
seems to have simply given up on trying
to contain the virus in a previous video
I said that based on historical trends
if we reopen the country before we had a
handle on the disease cases would spike
and we'd be forced to shut everything
down again and then we'd be worse off
than when we started
as much as I enjoy being right and
telling people I told you so this time
it's been incredibly disheartening to
watch before this new surge in cases all
50 states had started to reopen in some
capacity as of right now 17 states
remain fully reopened eight are in the
process of reopening 13 have paused
they're reopening measures and nine have
been forced to backtrack including Texas
and Florida where state leadership had
been eager to reopen even now with their
states in crisis and the eyes of the
world upon them Ted Cruz won't wear a
mask on commercial flights and Ron de
santis is pushing for reopening schools
it's obvious why America felt the need
to reopen so long before we were ready
our nation falls apart if there aren't
workers to produce value without
shipping and trucking we can't
distribute or export goods crippling
some of the world's largest corporations
without retail stores the country's
consumption engine begins to stall but
thanks to our negligence in creating a
nationwide standard of worker
protections American employees are stuck
between a rock and a hard place
and inability to pay their bills or
afford medical care on the one hand and
returning to work and contracting a
deadly disease on the other
unsurprisingly the u.s. chose to
sacrifice its citizens on the altar of
the free market and wouldn't you know it
stock prices went up and thousands died
from the virus the impressive thing
about the capitalist meat grinder that
is the American economy is that human
sacrifice works sure some of your
workers may die but the value of what
they produce is vastly greater than what
they're paid so it's no trouble to
replace them and so the cycle will
continue
you reopen spike stocks go up more
people die backpedal a bit and repeat
all the while repeating the mantra that
were all in this together and we're
doing the best we can both of those
statements are lies now those same
people are suggesting that we need to
reopen our schools let's talk about that
what are the current guidelines for
preventing the spread of kovat first and
foremost wear a mask this is the most
important part in keeping yourself and
others safe just looking at this video
should be enough to show you that masks
work another critical part of the
equation is maintaining at least 6 feet
between yourself and others social
distancing dramatically reduces the rate
at which the virus spreads from person
to person and that has been the case for
each pandemic we faced in the past
because the universe has a cruel sense
of humor
there were anti mask leagues during the
1918 flu pandemic and guess what
happened when there were large
concentrations of those people in one
area the same thing that's happening
today it was a stupid hill to literally
die on back then and it's even more
ridiculous today because we've seen it
happen before the final piece of advice
from the medical community if we're
ignoring just staying home because
apparently that's impossible is to wash
your hands frequently and thoroughly and
generally just follow good hygiene
protocols to recap wear a mask stay away
from other people and keep yourself
especially your hands clean
now imagine any child you know is that
child capable of following these
guidelines for 9 hours a day with
limited supervision of course not
children bless their little hearts do
some of the dumbest things imaginable
they climb all over each other they
can't follow even the simplest
instructions they'll do whatever they're
not supposed to do as soon as the
teacher isn't looking and their idea of
fun is spitting on each other and
licking doorknobs not exactly the ideal
group to dictate strict guidelines to
over the course of this pandemic we've
seen fully grown adults throw fits when
someone suggests they wear a mask we
have seen anti mask protests people
claiming kovat is a Chinese hoax people
who simply don't care if they get the
disease because quote it's not even as
bad as the flu if supposedly mature
responsible adults can't even follow
these basic guidelines how can we expect
boisterous little kids to do it or if
those same anti mask whiners have kids
what do you think the odds are they've
taught their children to be responsible
and wear a mask at school heck those
kids probably
already have the virus thanks to their
idiot parents so we stick roughly 57
million kids in school this fall most of
them don't follow guidelines because
they're kids and they don't understand
or just don't care
millions of them get infected they
infect their teachers many of whom are
drafting wills in case they die the kids
then carry the infection back home with
them their parents get infected and
we're even worse off than we are now
this is what will happen if we try to
reopen schools in the fall I'm going to
be very honest here as difficult as it
is to come to grips with the fact that
all learning must take place online this
year anyone who supports reopening
schools is part of the problem if you
are a parent you're not being a good one
sending your children into these plague
dens is incredibly irresponsible if
you're a teacher
your first charge is to care for your
students and provide a safe learning
environment that is impossible in
physical schools right now thankfully
many parents and teachers have been very
vocal about wanting the nation's schools
to remain closed for at least the rest
of the year this is the right approach
but let's have a listen to what
advocates for reopening have to say the
president has said unmistakeably that he
wants schools to open and I was just in
the Oval talking him about that and when
he says open he means open and full kids
being able to attend each and every day
at their school the science should not
stand in the way of this and as dr.
Scott Atlas said I thought this was a
good quote of course we can do it
everyone else in the Western world our
pure nations are doing it we are the
outlier here the science is very clear
on this that you know for instance you
look at the JAMA Pediatrics study of 46
pediatric hospitals in North America
that said the risk of critical illness
from kovat is far less for children than
that of seasonal flu the science is on
our side here and we encourage for
localities and states to just simply
follow the science open our schools it's
very damaging to our children there's a
lack of reporting of abuse there's
mental depressions that are not
addressed suicidal ideations that are
not addressed when students are not in
school our schools are extremely
important they're essential and they
must reopen first of all when you hear
the science should not stand in the way
of reopening that should be a huge red
flag
sure the science says many of these
children will die but they got to go
back you know nope that's insane
but let's address some of the other
points first she said everyone else in
the world is doing it yeah but the rest
of the world handled the crisis
responsibly and beat their outbreaks we
have not we're worse off than ever just
because the rest of the world gets to do
something doesn't mean we get to as well
that's just the u.s. acting like the
spoiled superpower it is she goes on to
say the risk for children is far less
than that of the seasonal flu okay so
you're saying it's a numbers game you're
saying there is an acceptable level of
infection and risk of death here
how many children dying is acceptable to
you five hundred a thousand five
thousand there's a vaccine for the flu
there's no vaccine for coronavirus
children will die if we put them all in
schools together of course this is the
United States we're talking about we're
used to children being killed in school
ignoring the fact that these people seem
very willing to sacrifice thousands of
children for the sake of normalcy she
goes on to say that while schools are
closed there are mental health issues
that are not addressed this is true the
pandemic has taken quite a toll on the
mental state of many people children
included if only there were some way to
guarantee that all these people had
access to the mental health care they
need something that was available to
everybody a sort of universal health
care if you will I'm being snarky but
here's the thing
what the White House press secretary is
suggesting is that by opening schools
mental health issues will go away
obviously that's not the case a trip to
the school nurse isn't going to solve
anything what would help in a situation
like this is universal health care which
neither Donald Trump nor Joe Biden
supports if we truly cared about the
well-being of our students we would make
sure that their mental health care needs
could be addressed regardless of their
parents financial situation with health
insurance tied to employment in the u.s.
since so many people have lost their
jobs they've also lost their health
insurance which means they will not be
able to pay the medical bills when their
children contract coronavirus and they
certainly won't be able to afford mental
health services which are often not
covered by employer health insurance in
the first place the people pushing for
schools to reopen do not care about the
safety of the children they have an
agenda
take for example Education Secretary
Betsy DeVos DeVos who has never worked a
single day in a public school has
consistently downplayed the danger of
reopening and has even threatened to win
hold funding for public schools that
don't reopen if schools aren't going to
reopen and not fulfill that promise they
shouldn't get the funds then give it to
the families to decide to go to a school
what that is going to meet that promise
well you can't do that I know I know you
guys the floors I know you support
vouchers and that's and that's a
reasonable argument but it's that you
can't do that unilaterally you have to
do that through Congress let's think
about this for a minute what possible
motive could Betsy DeVos a known
crusader for charter schools have for
pushing public schools to reopen it's
not hard to put two and two together
here she knows all those kids will be at
tremendous risk of infection she wants
public schools to fail to keep children
safe so she can say look see private
schools are better
let's defund public schools so we can
dump more money into already wealthy
areas to send their kids to charter
schools what she's doing here is
honestly just straight up evil she is
actively hoping for enough children to
get sick and even die that she can
achieve her goal these are the people
that are pushing to reopen schools
they're not doing it for the good of the
children they're doing it to advance
their own interests to defund public
schools to free up their workers to come
work in hazardous conditions for the
sake of the stock market to force an
appearance of normalcy to boost
re-election chances there are a lot of
powerful people behind this push to
reopen but parents teachers and students
all have a lot of power here especially
teachers there are almost 4 million
teachers across the country if they can
come together and say no we're going to
protect our students there's not much
those in power will be able to do
parents and young people support your
teachers send them letters of thanks and
encouragement ask them to stand up for
you and for your future tell those in
power that reopening schools in this
moment is not acceptable
I mentioned at the beginning of this
video that this kind of content is
supported by my patrons on patreon this
type of video while very important is
something that sponsors won't touch in
order to pay the bills and keep this
channel running I rely on Adsense
revenue sponsors and donations from
generous viewers by producing explicitly
anti-capitalist content I lose out on
both Adsense and sponsors if you enjoy
the kind of videos I'm producing and
you're able to chip in even a dollar a
month I would greatly appreciate the
support you can find my patreon page at
patreon.com slash second thought we also
have a lively and growing discord for
patrons of every tier you can check out
my previous episodes by clicking the
links on your screen thanks for watching
and I'll see you next week